eh bien on est sur la période d'ensilage
et culot il a ses limites
[Musique]
stéphane tapis chez le premier mec qui a
voulu me faire travailler ont été les
premiers premier 1er premier j'étais
avec lui dans un bureau ne sais pas
j'étais tout en train de faire des
photocopies je sais jamais pourquoi j'ai
mis mes joues c'est quand ils apprennent
que tu as un cancer ils viennent un peu
puis s'ils se mettent un peu plus loin
c'est pas quand c'est pas contagieux un
cancer c'est qu'il faut mais il faut le
banaliser il faut le désacraliser voilà
s'approcher encore plus n'ont pas besoin
d'être toujours vous avez toujours rêvé
de ça au vous engueuler encore encore
heureux
moi je sais que moi quand vous fait
mourir de rire les avaler de ccc c'est
incroyable sophie aussi avec lui reste
ils s'engueulent encore avec vous mais
même et puis on s'aime pareil et puis
auxerre les consignes paraît et puis ça
dure dix minutes serait qu'on était une
poignée de restaurateurs à vouloir
ouvrir très peu si on avait été
franchement si on avait été arrêté que
vous n'ayez pas été plus les clients
franchement ils étaient tous à apprendre
mais les réponses de restaurer
restaurateurs personnes on a été de 181
hier soir on a passé la soirée a appelé
tous les restaurateurs avec stéphane
expertiser les autres restaurateurs ab
vous qu on fait passage du coude parce
qu'à un moment donné lie avec la
décision qui vont prendre
on sait qu'il y en ait une qui va tomber
ça peut faire mal et puis éventuellement
il voulait peut-être faire enlever les
licences iv ils voulaient enlever les
droits d'exploitation c'est à dire que
six mois de mai m'enlève licence capte
droits d'exploitation tu vois la maison
puis terminez regarde l'image que
marseille a dans le monde voilà on a que
deux images aujourd'hui de marseille
c'est une avec une étoile ce qui leur
est ce ça existe plus et celle ci manne
servira aussi un dernières années dans
le monde
distri j'étais encore dans l'ombre à
comprendre pour un cours
si l'on dise dans l'ombre les trucs mais
je discutais de cuisine avec schubert
parler avec moi c'est vrai que par des
cuisines et toi occupe toi d'aller mener
les enquêtes de loana vous allez être là
tous les mardis pour nous faire une
petite analyse adéquate alors moi je
suis clairement fans de cette émission
je la trouvais sur les aides l'info que
je donnais c'est que malheureusement ce
garçon qui avait l'air très gentil s'est
fait tuer inondé d' insulte sur les
réseaux sur à celle admise cause de quoi
son polo rouge à cause de sanaa mardi
jeu dur c'est moi je trouve ça vraiment
mais ô dieu parce que la meilleure très
bon calibre vraiment s'il vous plaît sur
les réseaux soyez un peu cool parce que
moi j'ai quand même l'impression que sur
twitter on a fait le condensé de tous
les coins de france et on les a mais
c'est un critère parce que là twitter je
suis désolé moi je vous dire twitter
c'est un outil exceptionnel pour les
médias séance est ainsi passé au psg
c'est bon si vous voulez pas être connu
et qui voulait pas si vous voulez que
quand sur twitter vous arrivez vous ayez
que des vous êtes la plus belle rogner
zatla meilleur temps avez vous êtes la
meilleure vous êtes la plus belle ce que
tu fais c'est génial tu es toujours
magnétique et ben vous n'allez pas au
but
penser que les français sont disciplinés
mais ils sont plus que discipline et
vassy pouvait pas 10
personne ne peut dire que les français
sont pas disciplinés c'est incroyable on
est le pays le plus discipliné en europe
dit pas non à tel point qu'on en arrive
à ne pas confiné par ce parce qu'on
compte aussi sur la discipline des
français par l'apa en voiture à stores
l'asse on parle en parle un peu d'autres
parlent en général oui on a vu
qu'aujourd'hui on a tourné la chose est
dans ce qu'on appelle un petit plateau
montant ça veut dire que ça ralentit pas
mais ça veut dire que aujourd'hui rien
ne nous permet de dire que la semaine
prochaine ça va être catastrophique à un
plateau à 500 morts par jour exactement
ok juste mon père est rappelons le se
chiffrent le nombre de morts par jour
césar fait qu'on est tous conscients
qu'on combat tous quel qu'en soit le
prix et qu'on va jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui si on re confine on n'est
pas sûr d'avoir le salir confiné une
partie de sa région pour un nouveau
quatre couronnes un virus un nom à 500
morts par jour on se demande
si on peut encore attendre on oublie de
dire que la deuxième vague a été plus
mortel que la première première vague 30
35 mille morts là on a quarante cinq
mille morts et à l'heure actuelle il
n'est plus acceptable de mourir d'une
maladie pour laquelle on a vaccin ça
vient de moi j'y mourrai du corona virus
alors qu'il ya un vaccin disponible je
pense que jusqu'à un peu agacé sur le
côté walking dead parce que j'ai entendu
certains de vos confrères dire que dans
les quinze ans à venir on aurait des
virus qui serait infiniment plus
dangereux à ce qu'on vit quand on lis
actuellement et qui aurait un côté
celles d'aujourd'hui seraient des
bisounours à côté de cela est ce que
c'est vrai ça ou est-ce que cdma sais
pas si le pire est inexorable et je sais
pas si ça va être pire dans le futur ça
a déjà été fait à 10 en l'espèce humaine
et son système immunitaire ils ont
évolué au contact des agents infectieux
que maladies infectieuses il existe
depuis avant que l'espèce humaine existe
et que j'avais c'était déjà cet exemple
mais l'épidémie est 14ème siècle en
europe à lattes fait entre 30 et 50% de
la population selon les estimations il
pourrait y avoir un truc comme ça pour
avoir un autre truc comme ça
le oui à l'opa nous en aller j'avais
envie de faire un discours positif
d'annoncer ses 4 ces crédits car vous le
savez qu'ils épargnent pas du tout jure
sur la vita moi j'étais j'étais très
occupé hier mais qui ça va faire belle
émission animaux bah ouais ouais c'est
vrai qu'il est sur la chaîne animaux ce
chien voilà l'effet des cartons
d'audience dernière il a encore fait 55
téléspecteurs deux labradors trois
heures chacun coûte pas un centime
d'euro aux français c'est son frère et
je veux aussi dire que bernard montiel
était bien au courant de l'intervention
du président c'est vrai à merci
bachelier merci alors ça voilà ça c'est
un scoop
ouais ça n'est pas une dictature quand
un médecin propose impatient de porter
le masque de faire ceci ou de faire cela
le médecin pose une prescription vous
savez très bien qu'une prescription
c'est une recommandation
vous savez que le masque à l'origine est
une est un outil médical que les
chirurgiens ont pris pour éviter
justement de contaminer les plaies qu'il
ouvrait les patients qu'ils ouvraient la
part n'est pas porteur de l'inscription
à réalité c'est cette une prescription
médicale
c'est la furie du consentement ça veut
dire que je dois avoir le droit de
décider de prendre ou de ne pas prendre
de médicaments
donc ce que vous dites c'est pas être
magnifique si on se placer dans une
approche purement médical mais quand
c'est un décret qui même imposer le port
du masque dans lequel je n'ai aucune
explication ni scientifique ni médicale
ces dépenses de prescription c'est une
décision autoritaire ou politique qui a
pour finalité quoi ce que le mais ça dit
il faut qu'ils aient un signe extérieur
de viralité
il faut que les gens quoi participer à
l'immunité
il faut que les gens participent à une
approche culturelle ce sont les propos
de l'homme est lui-même qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui tu as même des cons qui
sont toujours dans la voiture avec leur
main cela on se protège enfin c'est ce
que j'ai fait c'est ce que j'ai fait moi
pour ma voiture je vous le dis tout le
démettre carlo alberto ça ne durera pas
mais ça risque au contraire de se
reproduire plus fréquemment si on ne
fait pas attention réchauffement
climatique c'est l'eau qui les
commettent d'autres messages qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire jouer ce qu'il faut
faire
je dirais simplement respecter les
objectifs de la loi qu'un que nous dit
la loi que eh bien on devrait atteindre
neutralité carbone plus émettre de gaz à
effet de serre pratiquement à horizon
2050 que d'ici 2030 on devrait diminuer
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
40% donc c'est inscrit dans la loi mais
nous ne prenons pas cette loi très au
sérieux puisque nous prenons du retard
par rapport à ce qu'il faudrait faire ce
qu'il faudrait faire est bien c'est que
chaque fois qu'on y met du gaz
carbonique l'utilisation de bas du
pétrole du gaz importants coûts du
charbon chez nous voilà c'est
essentiellement cela donc on sait ce
qu'il faut faire
les révélations incroyables quand le
couple avait la garde des enfants en fin
de semaine il leur serait arrivé le
matin après leurs débats comme ils l'ont
dit de convier ceci dans la chambre
parentale pour des jeux sexuels
le père de la plaignante lui aurait
alors proposé du joual orchestre avec
ses organes sexuels et ceux de sa
partenaire
les deux adultes et en u voilà avec
d'autres choses voilà qui sont révélés
autre chose en regardant sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya plusieurs interactions
entre collines et son père qui sont dans
la bonne humeur regarder je vous
montrais quelques messages qui ont été
postées par par coline notamment un
médecin une photo avec ses deux filles
photo à laquelle réagi richard berry agi
bon anniversaire la colline lui répond
amicalement enfin très gentiment merci
papa il ya d'autres échangent entre eux
sur le compte instagram notamment pour
la fête des pères dans lequel elle même
fait bonne fête à son as à son père dont
feraient que ça pose des questions sur
la nature de leur relation
est-ce qu'ils étaient réellement en
guerre ça date d'il ya quelques mois
seulement 21 jours 2025 par rapport à ce
qu'a dit guillaume
il ya des psychiatres psychanalystes qui
m'ont répondu aujourd'hui fin c'est pas
parce que on a l'impression pendant de
longues années où de longs moments que
les relations sont fluides qu'il n'y a
pas ce qu'ils ont comparées pour moi un
volcan un volcan chez elle qui a éclaté
une première fois en 2014 quand elle
s'est aperçue que la compagne de son
père attendait un enfant
premier éclatement et puis là ça peut
ressurgir il peut y avoir ce moment le
déclic où elle se dit je vais porter
plainte
et ce sont des moments de pulsions qui
peuvent être des moments de vérité
donc c'est pas parce qu'ils se sont
fréquentés sur un plateau il ya un an de
télé que tout ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui
est faux il faut faire très attention à
ça
[Musique]